I don't know if you saw Mike Pompeo our
Secretary of State was in the press
today saying that he thinks God did
appoint Trump to save the Jews from the
Iranian Menace and it just made me think
like when we were making Religulous
there was like a story every day that
you could have put in the movie yeah
we've-- it's never stopped it before it
never stopped
we've reached the point look humanity is
like in a death race between logic and
madness you know yeah we're like we're
relying on saviors why are we relying on
Trump or even Muller or the SDN why or
route you know these we don't need
Savior saviors or disappointments we
need reality you know and so this battle
between between the craziness and the
logic is going to result in some sort of
you know conclusion at some points who's
gonna win that is humanity gonna survive
that battle basically is what's going on
who do you who do you want in the 2020
field hey you're not in yet right Derek
didn't close close yeah this is only
there's only 15 in so you figure and
thoughtful fighting the good fight
because I agree with him that in my
opinion as a layman Trump is a traitor
and I'm yelling it arrest him arrest him
and meanwhile I feel like I'm invasion
of the Body Snatchers dude nobody
believes me except for you
[Applause]
you